introduce our next speaker who is
slightly you know less attractive less
funny all the stuff than me that I've
said a couple times and
um I first met our next speaker in 2017
in Boston at a sports analytics
conference
um after everyone knows who I'm talking
about but I'm not going to say his name
yet uh
but after the speaker gave his talk I
waited patiently after like a flood of
people went to ask him questions and uh
you know get his autograph and all these
things to ask my own question and it
turned out like six hours later all of a
sudden we were still talking and having
a conversation and I bring that up kind
of just to talk about uh the type of
person that he is the personality I
think anyone who's gotten to know him at
all has come to know him as just a
really genuine caring person whether it
deals with you know a little bit of over
enthusiasm for the r language which
actually isn't possible
um you know and being willing to like
help each other out build the community
whether it's with r or in Life or with
his family he just keeps revealing
himself to be a very special person and
he's a certainly a very special friend
who's meant a lot to me over the last
five or six years that we are here so
I'm not going to talk any longer I'm
just going to ask everybody's favorite
our guy Jared Lander to come to the
stage well thank you everyone
now I'm very excited to talk to you
today about deploying R And Friends into
a secure environment
so we're going to talk a little bit
about what that means what you need to
consider and like how you might go about
it
so first what are we actually talking
about you know what do we talk about
when we talk about deploying R in a
secure environment
it means mostly getting in the hands of
people who want to use it are in Python
and maybe Julia
and their Associated packages like you
want deep plier and ggpot
but you're not just going to use R you
want a code Editor to work with it you
might want our studio or Jupiter or vs
code
and if you use our studio or sorry posit
workbench then you get all three of them
right in there
but now you also want your add-on
packages so you might need a package
manager now this is not a sales pitch
for our studio but since we use our
tools and data science tools it's going
to be a lot of our studio in here
um you need a package manager you might
use our studio package manager or you
might use artifactory and you can host
cran packages Pi Pi packages you can
host git packages and you probably might
also in a secure environment want Linux
packages for either like a mirror of Apt
or rheel please use apt it's a little
easier for data science a lot easier
and if you're publishing you want a
publishing platform like connect to get
your shiny apps up or your markdown or
quarter documents or Jupiter or whatever
and there's a lot of tools we can talk
about we will focus on our studio pause
it but the idea is the same for all the
tools you might be putting up there all
right so
so I'll talk about a little other tools
a little bit but the idea is the same
so what do we deploy these tools on
where are they going
there's a few options you might have
you might do on-prem bare metal
and if you get bare metal you're really
lucky you're going to get raw
performance and that's really awesome
a little rare though not too many people
get bare metal anymore
a little more common is an on-premises
VM this has a lot of nice advantages if
you're ever afraid you're going to screw
it up you can just make a backup of it
and then like hey go break it it's fine
well not fine but it's better off if you
make an image plus you can resize you
want more RAM you want more processors
you got it
also common is a cloud VM and let's be
honest that mostly means AWS and Azure
maybe means gcp I would love to see some
people use digitalocean I would love to
see that get more traction but you know
you might use a cloud VM
or you might be installing into a
kubernetes cluster it's so hot right now
usually it's a managed kubernetes
cluster eks or Azure kubernetes or gcp
or digitalocean or linode or paper space
or whatever cluster you want to use
so we know we're going to deploy in one
of these four type spots
then we have to ask how locked down are
they how accessible are they this means
different things to different people
so there's a few different options
maybe you have your tool
exposed to the public internet
any one of the URL can access this tool
that's the setup we have seen but you
better make sure you have really good
authentication if you're doing that
because it's open to the public
a lot more common is that you have to be
inside your network the left side of
this image you have to be either
physically in the office or you have to
be VPN in to even reach the tool and you
see this a lot it's never a good VPN
like wireguard though it's always some
commercial VPN that just had a back door
disclosed the previous week that hasn't
been patched right but you know we deal
I wanted to put an image of nordvpn but
I didn't want to be that snarky
but you need to have some sort of access
to the network to even see the tool but
the key takeaway here is that the
machine you're installing on has
outbound internet access and that's
really important as opposed to our next
environment which is air gapped this is
two types of air gap this is a type of
air gapped environment where the right
side has no outbound internet connection
but it can talk to a different network
that does have an internet connection
and that will be very important
and that's opposed to this version of
air gapping where the right side network
has no internet and no access to any
network that does have internet
it is completely isolated
and we're going to focus on these air
gap scenarios today
so who is doing this what types of
organizations are air gapping or various
levels of security
pretty much everyone these days
Banks hedge funds insurance companies
have been doing it a little more a
little longer than others but
Pharmaceuticals and hospitals really
care about this manufacturing even
consumer goods are doing this now
they're taking it seriously no one wants
to be breached and of course the
government
is doing this they care about security
so how do these organizations know that
they can trust us as an outsider to do
this
you know who are we
so for industry and this is like private
and public companies
they might put us through a private
background checks like Sterling they
might make us take drug tests they'll
put us through their training like their
cyber security training training their
insider trading trading trading training
you get the idea I might put through a
bunch of different training programs to
make sure we're up to their snuff
now government they have their own
background checks
various levels of clearance
public trust for most agencies but if
you're doing intelligence or defense
secret top secret as such and it's not a
hierarchy just because you have top
secret doesn't mean you have public
trust you would need both same forms
different time frames but you need to go
through a process twice
and of course their own training which
is remarkably similar to the industry
training of different cyber security
inside of threat training it's they're
all getting from the same vendors it
seems
so now that they trust us how do we
access these machines how do we do our
job
well if you have the first type of air
gap Network where it can communicate to
another Network a little bit easier
we can ssh in through a into their
Network the exposed Network and then
through a Bastion box a jump box get
into the air gap Network and work of it
in there maybe it is a virtual desktop
in a browser various ways to get in
but if you have the more air gapped
Network I think that's the technical
term more air gapped
we can't ssh in
we need physical access to the network
often meaning we're sitting in a cold
room with no windows and we certainly
can't use our own equipment like this
person is
we'd have to be using equipment from
that company
all right so we're inside the network
it's time to deploy
the biggest thing I want everyone to
remember from this is that we're going
to use Docker for everything
everything goes inside docker
everything's better
so for our stack that we're talking
about we're going to talk about
workbench connect package manager
postgres and nginx
we find that gets you really far along
the way
so we need to build a Docker image for
each of these pieces of software
separately
so for workbench we need to install R
maybe python the basic packages we want
everyone to have Linux system libraries
very important and of course workbench
itself
I need to mount volumes for the home
directory so users can save their work
somewhere and for configuration files
then you need to configure the
authentication provider connection to
databases connection to metadata
databases a default r package repo and
what listed Port you're going to listen
to and maybe you're a Linux repo
for connect largely similar need R and
python basic packages system libraries
you need to install connected cells and
you need to mount the volume for where
the connect content is going to be
stored that needs to live on disk and be
persisted somewhere
and of course you need to configure very
similar to before authentication we're
going to get into that connection to
databases metadata databases
what URL you're going to serve it on and
you need to set up within you don't need
to you should in a good Ideal World set
up an email server
you don't always have that option though
a lot of places like nope no email for
you which you could live without
then for package manager R and python
notice a pattern here system libraries
package manager and then you need to
find a way to have it listen on a
certain Port if you're using git
packages you need to find a way to
authenticate against those git packages
either SSH or https maybe you have git
on the secure side there's all these
considerations you need to tell package
manager how to get there
now postgres what are we using postgres
for this is not postgres for data for
the data scientists to use
all of our software we've talked about
so far use postgres as a metadata
storage
so you need a postgres container
for each of those pieces of software
so you need to install postgres in the
container you need to mount the storage
directory and you need to configure it
mainly the listening Port you could have
one container for all three pieces of
software but it's better to have a
separate container for each just to keep
things really separate in case you want
to blow something up
happens a lot it's like unplugging and
replugging
and then you need some way to Route
traffic around to all of these pieces of
software
so you install nginx and you configure
it to know what URLs are going to what
services
how to deal security escalation if
someone says HTTP you want to bump that
up to https but oh no you're using https
so now you need SSL certificates ever
try using a self-signed cert it's really
painful so you need some way to deal
with all that so a lot of things need to
be configured
but let's say we'll get to that in a
second now that we have our images built
we're good to go right
you need to do vulnerability scans
you need to make sure the containers are
secure if we're handing this to a
customer we want to make sure
it's trustworthy
so you're going to scan every single
image and you often do this with
openvast or nmap there's various ways
but those are probably the two most
common ways we would scan an image and
then you're going to know about cves the
common vulnerabilities and exposures
some of them we can't do anything about
there's a CV in postgres we can't patch
postgres but we need to make sure the
client is very aware of any
vulnerabilities that might be in there
and now if we can change things which is
ideal
it's time to harden the images
need to make sure these things are as
locked down as possible
so you're going to remove any unused
Services if you're not using service why
is it in the image
you're going to close any unused ports
and then you want to avoid packages that
make internet requests they're sneaky
the Gert package which is a get
interface at installation time tries to
reach out to apps and install a Linux
package if it's not already there that
can really wreck your day
other packages like Arrow try to install
reach out to internet and install Arrow
luckily if Arrow if you use a pre-built
binary you can install it right in the
system and you're okay
but torch torch tries to install
libraries at load time when you say
library of torch so you need to do it
the first time get an error and then
point it to local libraries which
hopefully are already in your image so
you need to have a back and forth about
hey what packages are you going to use
because if they say they want to use
torch after the fact you're rebuilding
that image it's a lot of things to think
about
all right so we have our images they've
been scanned they've been hardened we're
happy
how do you get them onto the air gap
Network
well
the first network is where the air gap
network has access to an internet-facing
Network that's easier we get into the
internet-facing network and then we via
a jump box or a bash gym either SCP or
rsync the images over to the other side
then the other side you could Docker run
or Docker compose preferably
ideally the the secure side has a Docker
registry over there but then you still
have to get the docker images into that
registry but that's someone else's
problem
right but somehow you're getting the
images over via SCP or rsync
but what do you do if you have the air
gap Network where there is no outside
connection
you turn to the sneakernet
this literally entails putting images on
a hard drive or a CD or a DVD or a
reel-to-reel tape yes I've seen that
well I've seen people who've seen that
I've never seen it but someone in this
room I know has seen it
and then you physically move that over
into the secure area plug it in after
telling the right people
and move it over into that secure
network you're literally putting things
on hard drives and moving them does that
sound efficient no is it your only
option yes well you could use a DVD but
you know all right
then what about getting your R packages
and python packages over there
well actually a bit of a misnomer at
least package manager can only do R
packages in air gap mode right now
theoretically Pi Pi is coming soon you
would download the packages on a on the
internet Network
move them over either by sneakernet or
RCP just like before
okay great we have all the software over
there but we're talking about various
types of commercial software whether
it's our studio or artifactory or git
lab you need to activate licenses
you need to tell you have a right to use
the software
well
you can do an offline activation which
involves copying and pasting a bunch of
code into a terminal and a website might
not always work
some of these pieces of software have
license servers where the software you
have can communicate to a licensed
server on the internet-facing network
and that communicates to the software
vendor
cool if you can't do that some vendors
not all offer activation keys so there's
different things you might need to do
great
let's say we got our software activated
we now need to make sure our user
connections are secure
them and for this we need to work very
closely with it
first you might lock out people who are
not on the ax on the network it's like
network access security that takes care
of the general population but then we
need to properly authenticate maybe a
two-factor authentication and we need to
deal with SSL certs it's a headache
because you need a certificate Authority
because you don't want to self-sign and
you need to get the certificates onto
the end user machines that's not our
problem though
so let's talk about Authentication
you're most likely going to authenticate
with active directory saml OCTA or oauth
if the client can't provide that on
their secure network we could package
that up in its own Docker container to
ship with all the other software to get
it up there so there's various ways you
can do that
but if you're using a client auth you
need to work really closely with them
getting the right config because the
number one problem with deploying
software on secure or less secure
networks is authentication it always and
even maintaining stuff that's always the
biggest headache is authentication so
get it right because it's a closely
guarded secret that it doesn't want you
to have so you have to develop a good
relationship and make sure you have a
good you have a good good experience
with them
so then you need to secure your
connections to the database that the
users will be pulling data from because
the data is really valuable
and this comes down mostly to best
practices
you want your username your password
other things stored inside environment
variables and you never want them in
your scripts
or better yet you can use a service
account for the database connection and
set up a system-wide
odbc.ini file and that means all the
users are using the same user account
which is good when you're deploying
content so imagine a user
uses Kerberos our third option to
forward their Connect login information
to the database sounds great sounds more
secure right when that employee leaves
the company and you
shut down their account what happens to
their content that content no longer
works
so it's a good idea to have a service
account which connect will use to hit
the database
now you have this beautiful shiny app or
a flask app or a plumber API you need to
make sure that is secure
so again network access make sure people
can't get to network and authentication
make sure your publishing platform
whether that's connect or any other
product
has proper authentication that goes back
to working with it and getting all the
configuration for active directory or
Sam or whatever set up correctly
so we flew through a lot of things there
and the key considerations that I want
you to take away from this talk things I
want you to focus on are the type of
environment again whether it was Bare
Metal on-prem VM a cloud VM or
kubernetes that's going to make a
difference in how you're going to
approach this
then how locked down is the environment
is it of open to the internet do you
have to be in the network or is it one
of our air gap scenarios because that's
definitely going to change your approach
especially the type of air gap
then how are you going to move the files
across we talked about SSH tunnels and
sneaker Nets
those are your best options your only
options may be gotta figure out what
you're going to do and it's you know
what it's better to plan that in advance
and know what you're doing rather than
finding it out along the way
especially if you have deadlines to hit
then you're gonna have to deal with your
https and notice I keep bringing that up
it really pains me uh you have to deal
with your your SSL certs maybe you need
to use certbot plan ahead for this stuff
and then if you're going to use https
your customer needs to have not IP
addresses but URLs you need to have that
planned in advance all these little
things that just sort of add up and you
need to keep adding in it's not enough
that the Network's secure you need to
keep adding in all these little things
then you have Authentication
again
this is the hardest part of anything we
ever do of customers getting
authentication right and that is not
insurmountable that has nothing to do
with it being a secure network well it
is secure it has to If by you're
securing it by putting authentication on
there but that's any type of network you
need to make sure you get that right
because that could make or break the
whole installation
and if you do all that in the right
order
you'll be all set
so thank you